nous avions envie de revenir sur un
parti qu'on a publié ce week-end sur le
site du figaro sur ces 25 35 ans qui ne
veulent plus faire carrière ça a été
énormément vu beaucoup commenté
plusieurs centaines d'internautes ont
donné leur avis en gros cet article
décrit une génération où beaucoup
considèrent que le travail moderne et
aliénant c'est par exemple le cas de
quentin dont on donne le témoignage il
nous dit je n'ai pas envie de me donner
pour des entreprises qui ne veulent
faire que du profit gabriel cluzel est
ce que si ces nouveaux est-ce que ça a
toujours existé
on a quand même le sentiment mais c'est
un peu intuitif mais pour avoir des des
témoignages personnels dans nos
entourages respectifs que peut-être que
le rapport au travail à la nécessité de
faire carrière de se mettre dans une
logique professionnelle linéaire n'est
plus aussi prégnant qu'avant oui alors
il ya un aspect positif et un aspect
négatif la laisse d'ailleurs c'est
pardon je sais pas pour enlever le
mérite au figaro madame mais c'est pas
le premier journal a évoqué la question
je crois que loeb c'est le monde avait
fait des articles sur ce sujet c'est au
tour du premier oui et puis d'aidé de la
sensation de faire un travail final pas
de sens exactement alors en cela on se
dit que c'est plutôt noble c'est à dire
que les gens du tertiaire qui font des
métiers de service au nom imprononçable
qu'on ne peut pas même pas si tu as sa
grand mère parce qu'elle comprend rien
et bien se disent finalement je je je je
je travaille pour une grande boîte mais
cc je suis un esclave comme un autre le
salariat c'est une forme d esclavage et
je voudrais revenir à la terre revenir à
quelque chose qui produit de la valeur
ajoutée mais qui n'est ce pas seulement
de l'argent n'est pas seulement de
l'argent sonnant et trébuchant
et puis il y a un côté aussi négatif
et puisqu'il faudrait pas déjà être jean
de florette c'est-à-dire s'imaginer que
idéalisée
les métiers qui ont du sens parce que
tout métier finalement à sa part de
bullshit jobs justement à ça pas tous
ceux qui ont travaillé je pense que nous
travaillons tous il ya des moments dans
notre carrière ou et bien écoutez on
travaille pour se nourrir mais on trouve
pas ça toujours passionnant et chamarrés
et les gens racontent beaucoup dans les
boîtes que les stagiaires aujourd'hui
arrivait finalement dans un journal par
exemple ce serait bien à la place de de
l'éditorialiste quelquefois parce qu'il
trouve ça plus rigolo que de trier les
trombones rouge des trombones vert donc
c'est et puis c'est peut-être un peu un
rêve d'enfant gâté c'est à dire que ne
pas vouloir faire un métier sur des
rails c'est ses propres à une espèce
d'élite parce que j'avoue que quand on
est il ya des gens qui ont fait des
écoles de commerce qui doit être c'est
un peu faire un cep de pâtisserie puis à
des gens qui ont fait un simple et de
pâtisseries parce qu'ils n'ont pas
tellement eu de choix et reste pâtissier
toute leur vie ils se posent pas la
question parce qu'ils ont une famille à
nourrir ce qui est vrai c'est que cet as
le rapport à l'argent a peut-être changé
regarder cette cette étude qu'on vous a
dégoté elle était réalisée par l'iris
l'institut de recherches économiques et
sociales on interroge des jeunes qui ont
terminé leurs études en 2013 donc trois
quatre ans de vie active et dans ce qui
est important pour eux dans le travail
le niveau de rémunération arrive tout en
bas alors c'est peut-être parce qu'ils
n'ont pas encore beaucoup de charges
puisque ils sont jeunes je vous le
disais c'est des gens qui travaillent
depuis depuis trois quatre ans où c'est
peut-être parce que le rapport à
l'argent a changé qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
je pense que c'est le rapport au travail
qui a changé et quelque part c'est assez
positive c'est à dire que moi je que le
travail soit envisagée avec plus
d'insouciance et de désinvolture
c'est finalement la marque des sociétés
riches c'est à dire que ce sont les
riches qui peuvent se permettre le luxe
de travailler moins
il faut replacer dans un contexte
historique c'est à dire qu'au 19e siècle
il fallait travailler plus de 3000
heures par an pour s'offrir le niveau de
vie du 19e siècle aujourd'hui au 21ème
siècle on peut se remettre de travail et
1500 heures par an en moyenne pour avoir
le niveau de vie du 21e siècle est donc
aujourd'hui on remarque que bat même à
l'échelle géographique ce qui des pays
qui les plus pauvres sont les moins
productifs sont les lieux où les
travailleurs sont obligés de travailler
plus plus plus longuement
donc quelque part cette c'est ce
sentiment que le travail de
bien quelque part accessoires et doit se
subordonner à des besoins récréatif
c'est le signe c'est aussi la
conséquence d'un certain développement
économique dont il faut je crois se
féliciter en se rappelant aussi que ces
évolutions ne sont possibles que dans
des régimes économiques capitalistes où
le profit n'est pas mépriser et
contrairement à ce qu'on a pu entendre
ou il ya des gens pour accumuler du
capital avec une dizaine de travail de
bonne qualité un progrès techniques qui
nous permettront d'être plus productifs
et travailler moins et où il ya aussi
mathieu sous carte des gens pour payer
des impôts et des charges sociales
financées c'est vrai on peut le dire un
système social assez généreux des aides
diverses non ou c'est un discours
inaugural le pont est très habile mais
ce que je vais revenir
le moulin effectivement le rapport au
travail est ce qu'on peut se permettre
sans nom mais est ce qu'on peut se
permettre ça en france parce qu'il ya un
système social généreux beaucoup
d'amortisseur et que vous pourrez pas en
suisse c'est beaucoup c'est pas du tout
c'est exactement ce que j'ai à dire
c'est pas du tout propre à la france en
est ému parce qu au delà de ce que vous
évoquez en début d'intervention
on a tous dans nos entourages quelques
noms on a des études très sérieuses et
qui sont internationales qui démontre
effectivement que le rapport au travail
partout en tout cas dans nos pays
développés évolué et on peut s'en
réjouir comme le disait mon voisin à
l'instant en tout cas on ne peut pas
s'en étonner
pour une raison très simple il ya
effectivement le temps qu'on consacre au
travail qui n'est plus du tout les mêmes
aujourd'hui de ce qu'il était il ya deux
ou trois générations le temps de travail
rapporté autant de vies je cite souvent
le sociologue jean viard qui avait tué
17 façon très précise au jour nos
arrière grands parents travaillent et la
moitié de leur vie en fait 40% du temps
de vie c'était du temps de labeur pour
nous aujourd'hui c'est moins de 10 %
moins de 10% une vie c'est 700 mille
heures on travaille c'est la peur de se
mouiller là-dedans on compte les heures
de sommeil je parle je parle
effectivement puisque on dort pas tous
la même chose mais enfin une vie en gros
c'est 700 mille heures aujourd'hui on
travaille moins de 70 ni l'heure et pour
nos enfants qui naissent aujourd'hui
dont la vie du rapport à l'an 800 mille
heures ce sera encore moins de travail
ce qui veut dire que le temps de travail
est un petit temps de vie au milieu de
beaucoup d'autres temps sociaux le temps
familiaux etc et que donc intuitivement
que les jeunes générations revendique de
consacrer autant de soin et d'intérêt
aux autres tant de vie qu'au temps de
travail paraît tout à fait judicieux
on est un jeune homme moderne
aujourd'hui on revendique par exemple de
s'occuper de ses enfants
compte tenu du fait que nous sommes des
sociétés à quatre générations quand on a
40 ans on devient même jusqu'à 60 ans on
devient un aidant pour ses parents qui
vivent de plus donc on a des tas de
choses qui dans la vie nous accapare qui
ne relève pas d'un dix professionnels et
qui pour autant donne sens à notre vie
mais par ailleurs dernière chose le
travail aussi est investi de choses dont
on investissait pas avant pour le dire
simplement aux autres fois un travail
c'était une rémunération et un statut
social
aujourd'hui les gens revendiquent et une
rémunération et un statut social
quand même mais du sens d'ailleurs le
travail comme vecteur d'accomplissement
personnel et ça aussi en fait il faut
s'en réjouir
et ça ne concerne pas que les catégories
très favorisés qui font des écoles de
commerce et qui ensuite va l'être
pâtissier ça concerne absolument tout le
monde on se rend compte que dans toute
la pyramide dans toute l'organisation du
travail
on réclame du sens pour une raison très
simple le rapport au travail change
parce que on sait que la moitié des
emplois à échéance de 15 ans vont être
transformés ont dit qu'aujourd'hui un
jeune qui rentrent sur le marché du
travail va changer dix fois de métier de
statut de secteur d'activité
d'entreprises terre que la vie ou une
vie était égal à une carrière dans une
même entreprise sur un même poste c'est
fini pire les jeunes qui rentrent qui
naissent aujourd'hui en fait pour la
moitié d'entre eux le travail qu'ils
occuperont dans 30 ans n'existe pas
aujourd'hui comment se projeter
j'accuse s'invitant vous les voyez
changer les étudiants que vous voyez
passer à l'université on vous enseignez
n'ont changé moi sur le sur le temps
quand même assez court depuis que j'ai
commencé ce qui est clair c'est que je
pense que il ya eu des des perceptions
différentes je réfléchissais sur le le
sentiment de vide on vous dit
mais ce sentiment de vide quand on
imagine les temps modernes de chaplin le
travail à la chaîne c'était encore plus
un sentiment de vide ce qui est
différent et je vais dans votre sens
donc très très brièvement
c'est la priorité peut-être n'est plus
accorder nécessairement à
au travail comme ça pouvait être le cas
auparavant
je suis un peu je vous trouve un peu
optimiste sur mais vous avez cité la
sociologue donc on va pas critiquer
évidemment vos chiffres mais sur le
faible investissement du travail en tous
les cas c'est parce que je vois dans une
certaine catégorie de la population
imaginer un cabinet d'avocats
aujourd'hui c'est pas le peu de
pourcentage que vous avez dit donc je
pense qu'il ya des beaucoup quand même
de travaux qui sont très impliquant
demande énormément d'investissement ou
alors sont pas nécessairement très
impliquant mais avec des horaires
tellement on a souvent parlé de la
fameuse vendeuse qui est deux qui est
obligé d'avoir des horaires tellement
bizarre qu il est accablé le temps
partiel subi
donc en réalité je pense qu'il ya eu
vraiment aujourd'hui une crise tout de
même du travail du sens du travail ça
c'est une nouveauté puisqu'on lui on
espère lui accorder et lui donner un
autre sens et on ne le trouve pas ce qui
peut expliquer vos jeunes qui vont vers
une des recherches d'autres d'autres
vies devait alternative face à presque
une forme d'individualisme malgré tout
qui sous tend ces recherches c'est à
dire que autrefois vous étiez un exode
des exemples autour de nous un garçon
qui faisait une école de commerce
prestigieuse qui avait une école de
commerce ou d'ingénieurs qui avait
comment dire coûté des sacrifices à ses
parents se disait ou là bas je vais
quand même rester dans cette voie là
puis maintenant je suis marié il faut
bien que je gagne ma vie
est-ce qu'elle va quand même une part de
là aussi d'individualisme volonté de se
réaliser
et qui participe de notre côté et c'est
une question passionnante
malheureusement il nous manquera ton
pour y répondre je laisse le dernier
mois nos internautes
les 25-35 ans manque t'il vraiment
d'ambitions professionnel c'est assez
partagés petite majorité 53 % qui dit
non nicole estime que c'est surtout un
effet de mode plus ou moins liés à
l'écologie et les 35 heures n'ont rien
arrangé et romain qui dit les 25-35 ans
pense que tout arrive dans le bec si on
à bac plus beaucoup en restant assis
derrière un ordi dans un bureau eh bien
on peut vous le dire ça n'est pas vrai
merci beaucoup à tous les quatre bonsoir